Today we're going to talk about the transformation of the Roman Empire.
And I use the,
uh,
somewhat neutral,
an undramatic word transformation.
It can be fall of the Roman Empire collapse of the Roman Empire.
Be Clear that we're talking about the fall of the western empire.
Next week we'll talk about the survival of the eastern empire.
From four 10 to four 80,
the western Roman empire disintegrated.
It was dismembered by barbarian groups who were,
except for the huns,
not really very barbarian.
That is,
they were not intent on May ham and destruction.
All they really wanted to do was to be part of the empire,
to share in its wealth and accomplishments rather than to destroy it.
Nevertheless,
for 76 is the conventional date for the end of the western empire.
Because,
uh,
in that year,
a barbarian chieftain deposed a Roman emperor.
Nothing very new about this for the fifth century.
What was new is that this chieftain whose name is spelled all sorts of different
ways,
but in Wickham,
it's Oda Vase or sometimes these notice Oh,
away,
sir,
I would have a car.
Uh,
Odoacer a,
uh,
we don't even aren't even sure what so called tribe.
He belonged to a barbarian general deposed the child emperor Romulus Augustus,
who by an interesting coincidence has the names of both the founder of the city
of Rome and the founder of the Roman emperor.
The US on the end is little.
It's a diminutive,
uh,
so a man with this grandiose name,
a child deposed in four 76,
and instead of imposing another emperor,
Odoacer simply wrote to Constantinople it and said,
uh,
we're going to be loyal to you.
We will recognize you as the sole emperor.
Constantinople,
however,
was far away and while of symbolic significance,
this pledge of loyalty by Odoacer had no practical significance.
For all intents and purposes,
the western empire had enforced 76 become a collection of barbarian kingdom.
A kingdom is smaller than an empire.
We use the term empire to mean a multinational,
a very large state ruled from one center,
but consisting of many different kinds of pieces.
Kings and then term and title king is of German origin.
Kings are very powerful but over a more limited territory.
So there was a king of Italy.
Now there would be a king of the Franks or uh,
um,
France Franzia the former Roman goal.
There would be a king of the lombards later in northern Italy,
a king of the Visigoths,
first in southern France and Spain.
And we'll go over who is where at the beginning of next class for now.
We're going to talk about this collapse and its consequences and we're going to
orient ourselves around three big questions.
One,
why did the west fall apart
as it kind of corollary to that question,
was this because of the external pressure of invasions or the internal problems
of institutional decline?
Did it fall of its own accord or was it pushed,
in other words,
question number two or you know,
big question number two,
who were these barbarians and how romanized or how different from Rome worthy,
and that's,
we're going to talk about more in on Wednesday,
next class
and three,
does this transformation mark a gradual shift to another civilization or is it
the cataclysmic end of the prevailing form of civilization ushering in a
prolonged period of what used to be called?
The dark ages,
the dark ages,
roughly the sixth to 11th century.
This is a term we don't like to use.
Uh,
it implies a value judgment that is not only not necessarily accurate,
but also expresses a certain kind of point of view of what are good periods in
history and what are bad periods in history.
But I'd like to just probe this third question first.
And that is how severe a catastrophe was this.
So is it the end of civilization,
a La Planet of the apes or,
uh,
blade runner or any other kind of apocalyptic image we have?
Or is it merely a shift in power and the survival of Roman institutions such as
the church,
while Roman political,
uh,
infrastructure,
the emperor,
the console's,
the Praetorian prefects,
uh,
and so forth,
while that collapses,
uh,
a medieval historian named Roger Collins in a book called the early Middle Ages,
writes,
the fall of the Roman empire in the West was not the disappearance of a
civilization.
It was merely the breakdown of a governmental apparatus that could no longer be
sustained.
The key word here is merely
the destruction of the Roman political apparatus may simply mean that the Roman
state ceased to function,
but that everything else continued.
But really the question is could everything else continue in the absence of a
state and have a political order?
The destruction of the political order also means after all the destruction of
the military system.
When we opened this class,
we talked about a civilization built on such things as the rule of law and the
maintenance of peace.
These are no longer possible if there is no military governmental structure,
as we'll say a little later.
To some extent,
people didn't know that it was the end
because for a while things have seemed to go on as before.
People were speaking Latin,
they were living in cities.
The cities were much less populated,
but nevertheless,
they were still there.
There were still rich people.
There were still poor people.
Um,
in retrospect though,
we can see that things really did change.
How much they changed is the subject of a lot of historical controversy.
The world of late Roman historians is divided roughly speaking between
catastrophist and continuous.
As you may guess,
the catastrophist think the fall of the Roman empire,
whether we dated for 76 or there's some reasons to date it,
really five 50 for reasons we'll learn in the next week.
Between four 50 and five 50,
a catastrophe happened.
A civilization was wiped out.
And,
uh,
really,
um,
uh,
if not literally a dark ages,
a more primitive,
uh,
more warlike,
more illiterate and more rural period was ushered him.
Okay.
The disappearance of ancient texts,
things that the Romans knew from that last Hortencia is dialogue of Cicero that
Augustine was so fond of,
uh,
to,
many other kinds of works that,
um,
had been known to the Roman world.
Right?
I can't remember exactly how many plays aesculus rope,
but it's something on the order of 60.
And we have three.
Um,
so the disappearance of texts,
the end of literacy,
except for a very small portion of the Christian clergy,
a more primitive architecture,
the end of grand civic projects like,
aqueducts,
coliseums theaters,
Babs,
a more isolated society without these urban centers.
I diminished population spread across the country side,
mostly engaged in subsistence,
hence the,
if not end of trade,
the radical diminution of trade.
The continuous people like Collins who might just quoted see the political
changes as dramatical,
right,
but as essentially surface phenomenon based,
partly on archeology and partly on a more sympathetic understanding of Christian
practices.
In other words,
they don't think that the proliferation of churches,
saints Colts is necessarily a sign of primitiveness.
So based on both archaeology and an understanding of Christianity,
these continuous point to the survival of trade,
the
role of bishops and other church officials as replacing the Roman governors,
the Roman political order may have collapsed in terms of staffing by lay people
and military people.
But the bishops were now the rulers of the city.
The bishops would now do things like ensure the food supply Rally v uh,
local population against barbarian invasions,
educate the populace
and the barbarian kings themselves try with some success to perpetuate the Roman
order.
They collect taxes,
for example,
may or may not be a good thing.
They engage in some kind of public works,
some kind of maintenance of order.
The civilization of the sixth and seventh centuries in what,
uh,
comes to be considered western Europe rather than the western Roman empire is
not radically more Barb arised or primitive that in the late Roman Empire bus.
The continuous my own position,
but I don't hold to it.
Dogmatically is that of a moderate catastrophist uh,
I,
uh,
something really happened,
I think it's pretty radical.
Um,
and uh,
it didn't happen all at once.
However,
for 76 is not the year of collapse a,
it is a process.
I'm fascinated by the degree to which people were and were not aware of the
cataclysm,
but I believe there is a cataclysm Wickham,
the author of this book that we're starting now,
the inheritance of Rome.
Chris Wickham straddles the fence as you've seen,
his chapter that you were to read for today is entitled crisis and continuity
400 to five 15.
Um,
I would never use a chapter title like that cause it's really frustrating,
you know,
which is it dude.
I mean he's,
he's,
he's the,
he's the leading medieval historian in the English speaking world.
Uh,
he is a cicily professor at all souls Oxford.
And if that doesn't sound impressive,
uh,
you're not a while.
It takes a lot to impress you.
He's a very great historian.
Uh,
but I don't like that chapter title.
As I said,
I would emphasize that crisis or change or cataclysm.
Well,
let's ask what happened beginning with the gradual involvement of the barbarians
in the military and their entrance into the empire.
We're using the term barbarians,
which goes back to the Greek term applied to outsiders,
people outside,
but threatening
the Greeks,
defined barbarians as uncivilized by reason of their speech,
which sounded to them in coherent by reason of the fact that they're nomads.
People who lead settled lives don't trust no nomads,
almost extinct in our world,
once,
uh,
dominated many geographical regions,
and we're frightening because they moved around to people who liked order and
familiarity.
They didn't live in cities,
whether there were nomadic or not.
Barbarians were illiterate.
This is the Greek idea of barbarians.
In the case of Rome,
there is no single definition of barbarian society.
We can say that Rome was overthrown by a warlike,
but not very fierce group of enemies.
And I use enemies in a very mild sense.
The Romans perceived them as enemies.
The barbarians perceived Rome as simply a nicer place to live,
okay?
But there is no Mongol hoard kind of event here.
They're not that frightening.
The Romans had known them centuries.
Most of them weren't even Christians.
Heretical Christians,
okay?
They're Ariens a R.
I.
A.
N.
S.
I remind you,
but they're not,
uh,
unfamiliar again,
even in their religion.
Okay?
They had been at the borders of the Roman Empire for forever,
like most empires.
Rome was that the one hand very aggressive and on the other hand,
thought of itself as peace loving.
It maintained the Daniel Bryan frontier as a kind of natural frontier every so
often crossing those rivers to punish German tribes who were probing the
frontiers of the empire.
But generally speaking,
the Romans were not interested in what they perceived somewhat inaccurately as
endless forests inhabited by primitive
people.
The continuous argue with some justice that between two 50 and 600,
what changed was not that primitive warriors conquered a civilized state in a
way that say the Mongols conquered China in the 13th century,
but that the ancient world became the medieval world.
That is an urban culture became more rural,
a Latin culture became al amalgamated to a German one.
Pagan Society became Christian.
Having said this,
it's nevertheless true that the most dramatic event of the fifth century is that
people who had been outside the empire,
we're now in it.
If we ask why the western empire collapsed,
the simple most immediate answer is it was taken over by German confederations
tribes.
They came not so much as conquerors,
as military recruits or as allies or as refugees.
So rather than as guys with knives in their teeth hacking and slashing and
burning,
they came as pathetic refugees and maybe doing some hacking,
slashing and burning,
uh,
as military recruits and as military allies.
Again,
not without a certain amount of HSP
hacking and slashing and burning,
but,
uh,
you know,
not a cataclysmic amount.
They admired Rome.
They want it to continue its institutions.
They regarded Rome as rich,
and that's civil law.
The last thing they wanted was to still live in kind of little huts in the
forest.
They were not the bringers of a revolution.
They were not even that numerous amounting to some tens of thousands.
Okay?
Nevertheless,
they ended.
Roman government accelerated the changes we've already described towards deep
population.
De-Centralization ruralization
a more,
uh,
a less cultivated,
less literate,
less Mediterranean centered society.
So I want to be given the description of this process by the changes in the
Roman army.
We saw the Diocletian around 300 d militarizes.
Roman government pays for the,
perhaps doubling of the military presence of the Roman army by,
uh,
changing the taxation system.
So the twin pillars of the empire in the fourth century,
our army and taxation,
the latter requiring a civilian governmental apparatus.
The army was a problem in terms of the recruiting of soldiers.
This may have to do with the population,
it may have to do with the unattractive nature of military life.
But nevertheless,
there was already in the fourth century,
a tendency to get,
uh,
the more familiar barbarians into the army as Roman soldiers because they were
available.
They weren't near the frontiers.
This may seem odd,
why hire your potential enemy to be soldiers?
But there's a lot of precedent.
Very often empires don't really want to supply their own manpower.
And the people who are the best soldiers are also the people who may in the
future be most threatening.
I don't want to pursue this similarly,
but the Afghan mujahideen were trained by Americans because at one time they
were opposed to the Russian occupation of Afghanistan as it happened.
In retrospect,
that had some bad consequences.
But at the time it seemed like a good idea.
So in the three,
seven days,
a group called the Visigoths asks to be admitted to the Roman Empire as an
allied army.
In other words,
the whole group
will be federated with the Romans and Federer.
Rati is the term given for barbarian troops serving under the Roman empire.
Why were they on the move?
These not really nomadic people.
They don't,
you know,
they don't travel and live in Yurts or uh,
uh,
travel across Central Asia.
They tend to be settled in villages.
They have dairy cattle rather than,
you know,
some kind of a nomadic sheep or something like that.
Uh,
they're pretty settled.
Nevertheless,
in three 78,
they were on the move and uh,
we don't know why some enemy pushing them across the Danube into what's now
Romania,
maybe the weakness of the empire,
they may have seen that the empire was not so strong and made a proposition kind
of like a,
a takeover,
you know,
you don't seem to be doing so well in your,
uh,
stock or your,
um,
finances.
So we're going to,
we're going to infuse some capital a.
Our soldiers.
They also may have been hungry certainly once they crossed the frontier,
the Romans were rather inept in feeding them and supplying them and the
Visigoths rebelled.
Okay.
Thus far,
nothing incredibly knew.
What really was new was that the emperor came and with an army to suppress them
and rather to his surprise and everybody else's,
the emperor valence was defeated
at the battle of Adrian nopal defeated by the barbarians.
Yup.
Being allowed in this federal,
what did they get from the Roman Empire?
Like did they agree to fight for that land?
May agreed to fight for them and they got a combination of land or supposed to
get land or territory and,
um,
some kind of maintenance in kind and or money.
The question was about the,
what the Visigoths as federal rotting got out of this deal or we're supposed to
get,
mmm.
The defeat of valence was not immediately cataclysmic because even though he was
killed at this battle,
even though it sent shock waves throughout the empire,
um,
in fact,
it would not be this area that succumbed to the barbarians.
The east Romania
or the Balkans would be part of the eastern empire.
And indeed both Adrian,
opal,
the city and Constantinople,
the even greater city would withstand visit gothic attempts to take them in
three 82 the Visigoths were officially recognized and they were allowed to
settle in the Balkans as federal rati and in fact they were reasonably useful
troops to the Roman Empire in the three eighties and three nine days.
What this does show,
however,
is the Barbara's one of the army and another aspect of that is that the army
tended to be commanded.
Now more and more by barbarian generals.
These barbarian generals at the top bore the title McGeester militant master of
the soldiers,
so I'm using the term general as a anachronistic one since that's what we're
familiar with,
these mid guests tree,
we're powerful leaders,
charismatic leaders of German or other tribal groups
who then ruled in the name of or behind the throne of the emperor.
They couldn't be emperors themselves.
At least in these years.
It was impossible to envisage a barbarian emperor,
but they held more power than the emperors.
Two of these generals or war leaders [inaudible] still echo
and Alaric still echo was a vandal Alaric was a visit Goff Alaric wanted
territory food treasure from Rome.
The Visigoths were moving from the Balkans into Greece,
eventually into Italy.
Still Echo played a kind of game with Alaric trying to keep him in check in the
name of the Western emperor,
but also negotiating with him.
Okay.
The emperor's moved from Milan in the north to Ravenna,
a little bit to the east.
Ravenna then was in the marshes and impossible for a barbarian army to take mrs
the last capital of the western Roman Empire.
Kind of romantic but and mysterious but strange as a place to end up.
Okay.
These are the Visigoths then who are on the move in the three nineties and the
four arts eventually
still echo would be executed by the Roman emperor of the west and our wreck
would invade and plunder Rome.
In four 10 it was the Visigoths who engineered the so called sack of Rome that
so shocked Augustine and his contemporaries
where you might be asking in all of this was the Roman army.
Alaric was wandering around the Balkans and Italy for two decades before he
sacked Rome.
The army which had consumed so much of the resources of the Roman Empire is
curiously absent in the history of the fifth century.
This is not,
you know,
the the eastern front in World War II.
This is something altogether different.
The collapse of an empire that expended huge amounts of treasure on its army.
It's army seems to be invisible and supports to some extent or that fact
supports to some extent the argument that the Roman Empire collapsed of its own
internal disorders.
Since we don't see it losing pitched battles to outside barbarians
or maybe the army doesn't disappear,
it becomes indistinguishable from the invaders.
The army is the invaders
creepier.
Now within this,
there are some real barbarians.
The hands,
the hands are kind of nomadic.
Okay.
They didn't actually cook their meat by holding it between their thigh and the
horse,
uh,
hide and the sweat and heat of the horse heated up the meat.
This is a widespread myth of nomadic peoples though that Chinese say this about
the Hmong goals.
Uh,
the Romans about the huns,
but they were pretty,
they were pretty mean.
Um,
they were interested in the Roman Empire,
mostly for plunder,
and they didn't care if that destroyed,
uh,
the,
economic base because they weren't thinking in such terms.
And indeed they may have frightened the rather nice German tribes that stood
between them and the Roman Empire in the four fifties.
The hunts where United under the leadership of a tele,
Eh,
and,
uh,
Attila certainly threatened
the eastern empire first,
but the eastern emperor defeated the Huns,
discontinued tribute to them.
And in a pattern that we'll see repeated again and again.
The huns decided that Constantinople was too tough,
that the eastern empire as a whole access to which was more or less controlled
by Constantinople,
was too well guarded and they turned to the West instead.
Not as rich maybe,
but much easier pickings.
They show up in Gaul in four 50.
They were defeated by an army of Visigoths allied with uh,
Romans
are they then went to Italy.
They went into the heart of the empire,
sacked cities in the northeast of Italy
and there's no army.
The emperor is holed up in Ravenna,
basically shuts the door,
gets under the bed and waits for it to go away.
But one power of Italy willing to try to deal with a teller is the bishop of
Rome whom we haven't heard of yet.
What we're going to be hearing about him a lot.
And indeed in the course that follows this even more,
the bishop of Rome,
the Pope,
Pope Leo the first,
along with two senators from the Roman Senate,
goes up to northern Italy to Ramon straight with a teller to visit the leader of
this barbarian tribe in four 53 to try to get him to stop plundering Adelai
whether they were successful or not,
doesn't much matter because until it died,
shortly thereafter of a brain hemorrhage and with his charismatic leadership,
the huns came to an end as a military force.
That is with the end of his leadership,
the Huns,
uh,
no longer had a as imposing a military force and quickly disintegrated.
What's significant is that it's the pope who is taking over what we would think
of as the Roman imperial responsibilities.
And this will be a pattern not only in the assertion of paypal power,
but in the way in which the church starts to take over many of the roles
abandoned by the empire.
Okay.
MMM.
Yeah.
After this,
the barbarian generals in effect take charge.
The hunter defeated,
but the other groups now pour in to the empire.
The vandals have taken over north Africa by this time,
by four 30 cutting off the grain supply to Rome.
They are unusual among the barbarian groups in the bay have a navy,
I know how to use boats,
and indeed they plunder the city of Rome in four 55 in a sack.
That might've been worse than that of four 10.
Okay.
By four 70,
the Visigoths control southern gall,
what's now southern France,
a group called the Swayze are in Spain.
Yeah.
The vandals in North Africa.
A group called the Ostrogoths in what's now Hungary,
the angles and the Saxons in Britain,
all that effectively remainder of the western empire.
When Odoacer overthrew Romulus Augustus was Italy and enforced 76
that's it.
A little Coda.
However,
in for 93,
the eastern emperor in Constantinople convinced the Ostrogoths
to get out of Hungary and stop threatening the eastern empire and take Italy
from Odoacer.
Once again,
the eastern empire is capable of deflecting barbarians into the West because
they're too strong.
So in four 93,
our friend Odoacer was overthrown by the physical,
uh,
Ostrogoths
and their leader Theodoric.
So what's the impact of all of us
on the ground?
If you were looking around in four eighties for nineties,
you would see a kind of accommodation.
The Roman elite accommodated themselves to compromised with negotiated with
their new rulers.
So for example,
a member of a very wealthy Roman family man named Snowdonia Cipolla narrows in
southern France.
It was eight bishop and a great land owner.
And we have a lot of letters of his,
the tell us about his negotiations with the visit.
Gothic King,
you're a wreck.
He found the visit,
golfs,
uncouth,
hard to deal with.
Not Knowledgeable of the Latin classics,
but not very frightening either.
Not particularly formidable.
So accommodation,
uh,
improvisation.
We have a saint's life that is a biography of a saint,
a man named,
I'm sorry that I'm writing on the board so much today.
Usually as you know,
I'm a little more in control,
but these are great names and,
and some of them are good cat names or dog names to several wryness of Nora Cup.
You know,
stop scratching the furniture,
set rightness,
that kind of thing.
Several dryness of [inaudible] a saint in what's now more or less Austria.
His life tells us,
uh,
that,
um,
he learned of the end of the Roman Empire this way.
At the time when the Roman empire was still in existence,
the soldiers of many towns were supported by public money to guard the frontier.
When this arrangement ceased,
the military formations were dissolved and the frontier vanished.
The garrison of Pasa cause still a town in modern Bavaria.
The garrison at pal out,
however,
still held out some of the men had gone to Italy to fetch for their comrades,
their last payment.
This resembles,
you know,
a corporation.
Somebody actually was telling me yesterday they'd worked for Eastern Airlines.
I company that went out of business in 1990 and so sudden was the collapse of
eastern even though it had been predicted that,
um,
she was a flight attendant and had to get on another airline in order to get
home that she lived in New York.
She was in Florida.
Eastern cease to exist.
So these soldiers are in the same position.
They want to get their last paycheck.
They were never heard from again.
Nobody knew that they in fact were killed by barbarians on the way.
One day when saint several wryness was reading in his cell,
he suddenly closed the book and began to saw the river he said was now red with
human blood.
At that moment,
the news arrived at the soldiers had been washed ashore by the current.
Interestingly enough,
he doesn't just stay in his cell and pray.
He starts to organize this society.
He is active although some of it involves some miracles in poor relief.
He deals with the local barbarian king,
King of the alimony.
Okay.
Vermont's straights with him.
He helps in diverting,
owed away Sar into Italy.
Okay.
Again,
like Pope Leo,
we have a member of the church and in this case somebody that you would think
was a wreck lose indeed had been living like a reckless.
Nevertheless taking over the responsibilities for a population abandoned by its
civilian government.
That is then one of the forms of accommodation.
Another aspect of this era,
however,
is declined.
The urban population declines.
The society and economy experience.
What Wickham euphemistically calls a radical material simplification
term.
He uses,
I believe on page 95 and one o five radical materials.
Simplification means that your standard of living plummets,
crude or ceramics.
Instead of that Nice North African red slip where you've got kind of mud that
you baked at home.
Fewer imports,
no pepper,
more homemade crude building materials,
fewer luxury goods.
The vandal control of North Africa met the,
meant the end of the Roman wheat supply.
The countryside of Rome had not grown enough wheat to feed the city since 200 a
d a BC.
So for 600 years minimum Rome was dependent on other sources of supply.
Southern Italy,
Sicily,
North Africa.
The moment the vandal supply of the vandals cut the supply,
the city could no longer support its massive population,
could not feed everybody.
When you multiply this phenomenon,
it's not a surprise that the city's decline in population and that the society
becomes more rural,
more agricultural,
more subsistence.
And here's where I think Collins is naive to speak of merely a political decline
without a government and military structure.
Trade could not take place on the scale it had before and without that trade,
cities could not serve off.
There is no denying a decline in culture,
economy,
and population.
Let's just look at Roman population figures
based on things like pork supply figures,
public,
I mean,
nobody took a census in rumps.
you know,
we don't really know exactly how many people live there at any given time,
but historians and archaeologists looking at things like food supply,
public welfare payments,
water delivery figures for aqueducts and the abandonment of houses and of
building sites.
Probably in five BC,
the Roman population was 800,000 that would be a fairly conservative estimate,
maybe as much as a million,
but definitely 800,005 BC.
Yup.
Is it just the city of Rome?
Just the city of Rome?
Yes.
Just the city of Rome
at the time of Constantine,
sort of where we begin the course more or less,
three early fourth century,
the population had declined probably to 600,000
after the sack of Rome in four 19 probably
300 to 500,000 obviously these are very rough figures,
but after the sack of Rome,
more than half of the population that had existed in five BC is gone
with the declared the end of grain shipments from North Africa.
We don't really know immediately.
We can estimate that by five 90 there could not have been more than a 150,000
people in Rome.
This is after not only the vandals,
but after a catastrophic war in Italy,
launched by the Byzantine Emperor.
Justinian can we'll be talking about next week.
Okay.
In 800 on Christmas Day,
Charlemagne was crowned in Saint Peter's in Rome as Roman emperor by the pope,
an act who's implications we will be exploring towards the end of the class.
On that day,
Rome must've had maximum maximum,
most optimistic estimate,
30,000 people.
This does not necessarily mean that they were primitive,
but they were living in the coliseum.
For example,
people built houses in there.
They use the walls of the coliseum as a fort.
There is a certain planet of the apes quality.
In fact,
Rome still to this day is filled with picture rescue ruins.
Even though it is a city of two and a half,
3 million people.
As I said,
people were not necessarily aware of this change.
For example,
lots of churches were built at this time and some of them have mosaic payments
that pavements that have mottoes about the grand juror of the Roman name.
Usual classical kind of mottoes.
Okay,
but then again,
people often aren't aware of what's happening to them.
I mean,
what if somebody in the future points to the fact that new haven in 1920 had far
more people living in it than it does now.
New Haven lost a third of its population between 1950 and 1980
what if some future historian is scandalized at the fact that in order to get
into Yale a hundred years ago,
you had to know Greek and Latin?
If you look at what those gentlemen see students had to study or we're
responsible for in say,
1925,
it's extraordinary.
It's not very impressive in the sciences,
but the decline of the humanities,
if by decline we mean things like knowledge of classical literature is stunning.
Somebody may decide in a few hundred years that the dark ages began in about
1950 and that those pathetic people in say 2011 impressed with their little
technological toys.
Nonetheless,
didn't know anything.
Now,
I don't actually believe that there are some people who do.
There's a philosopher at Notre Dame and a Alister McIntyre,
who,
who really believes that the dark ages began a long time ago,
and we simply don't know.
We simply refuse to recognize this.
Uh,
I was impressed by an obituary for men and Patrick Leigh Fermor,
uh,
who died at the age of 96,
um,
earlier this year.
Uh,
this is the last of the Great British characters of the 20th century.
He not only was classically trained,
wrote a lot about Greece,
lived in Greece.
Uh,
he in World War II,
um,
uh,
disguised himself as a Greek shepherd in Crete,
engineered the capture of a German general and the delivery of that general
after three weeks of hiking through the mountains of creek to a British
destroyer.
Um,
it's in a movie called,
um,
ill met by moonlight if you ever want to check this out.
Not a great movie,
but Patrick Leigh Fermor also wrote two books out of a projected three about
walking from Holland to Constantinople,
Constantinople or Baghdad actually I think in the 1930s.
Um,
but the obituary describes,
uh,
a conversation he had with this general,
this German general whom he is,
you know,
kind of trying to get across Crete and the general at one point over some fire
in the wilderness quotes aligned from Horace,
the Roman poet that then Patrick Leigh fermor finishes for him and indeed quotes
the next two stanzas.
Uh,
well that world is over.
That world is over.
Uh,
I don't pretend to be part of that world either.
Um,
and that's a world that would have existed in the time of Horace,
the years after Horace who lives,
um,
at the time of Augustus,
uh,
this would have existed in 300 d it would have existed at least in a few
monasteries in 880.
It would have flourished in the Britain of the 18th and 19th and early 20th
centuries.
Okay.
So,
uh,
again,
I,
I don't think that civilizations but civilization came to an end.
Yeah.
What came to an end was a civilization,
a certain kind of society.
It has some EHRs,
however,
like all dead entities,
there are four heirs to the Roman empire.
One is the Byzantine Empire,
the eastern Roman Empire,
which calls itself Vo Roman Empire doesn't call itself the eastern,
doesn't call itself the Byzantine.
It calls itself the Roman Empire even though it does.
So in Greek.
Second air are the barbarian kings.
We'll be talking about them on Wednesday.
They are attempting to a prop up the remanence of Roman culture,
civilization and material society.
The third air in some ways is Islam,
which we meet in the seventh century,
the century of its invention.
And the fourth area is the church.
Even though the church grew up in opposition to the Roman Empire,
it will preserve Latin cities,
learning classical civilization.
Okay,
so barbarians on Wednesday.